-Our next guest
is a talented actress
you know from shows like
"How I Met Your Mother"
and "The Avengers" films.
She stars as Ann Coulter
in the limited series
"Impeachment:
American Crime Story,"
which airs Tuesdays only on FX.
Let's take a look.
-George, we're celebrating.
These tapes are going to be
in the Smithsonian one day.
We're living a page
in a U.S. history book!
-I'm just saying maybe we
should hold off on celebrating
until we know for sure there's
something usable on those tapes.
-This is a coup d'etat,
and we're the coup.
Do you know how rare that is?
If there was ever a night
to crack open something
[bleep] decent, it's now.
We're starting.
♪♪
-Please welcome back
to the show our friend
Cobie Smulders, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Cobie.
-Hey, buddy.
-Cobie, I just want to say.
It is an excellent -- You have
an excellent Ann Coulter.
-Oh. Thank you, thank you.
It's been a journey, my friend.
-Do you find
it's an effective voice
to use around the house
with your husband and children?
-Oh, gosh. I wouldn't bring it
anywhere near Taran, but --
Um, I will say,
when I was in production,
I would read to my daughters
a lot at night
with the Ann Coulter voice.
And I would always ask first
because it already
makes every character
in the book really sarcastic.
[ Laughter ]
Which -- You don't find a lot
of really sarcastic characters
in children's books.
You know, you'd be surprised.
Um, but, yeah,
I'd be reading like...
[as Coulter]
"He would climb up her trunk
and swing from her branches
and eat her apples."
[ Laughter ]
And they'd be like,
"Mom, can we go back
to your voice, please?"
[ Laughter ]
-You had helped --
You were helping out,
I should say, with some
child care, not your children.
You have three new nieces,
nephews. What are they?
-I have two new nieces
and two new nephews,
but there is a set of triplets
in there.
So, I was just up in Canada.
There they are!
-It's kind of stunning.
I know triplets exist,
but it's really stunning
to see them all at once.
-And it's really something else
to try to hold them all
in your lap.
I mean, that was
a terrifying moment for me.
But, yeah, so it's like
every family member
decided to have babies
at the same time,
and my brother
really outdid everyone.
-Yeah. I know your husband,
Taran Killam,
to be someone
who is highly invested
in the holiday of Halloween.
He is a man
who loves a good costume.
Do you share this passion?
-You know, um,
they say opposites attract.
And that'd be our case.
I literally have nothing.
I have no costume.
My husband is set.
Our kids are set.
You can see our house
from outer space.
It has so many lights on it.
But I am like -- I think
the other day, I was like,
"I know what I'll be!
We got a kitten
a couple months ago.
I'll be a crazy cat lady!
That makes sense!"
And my whole family is like,
"Okay, Mom."
-Do you feel like the children
resent you for not taking it
as seriously as Taran,
or do you think they're fine?
-I mean, I think they resent me
for a lot more,
but I think we could
put it on the list for sure.
Um, yeah, so, I mean,
I'm more about, like,
I'm going to help you
get that candy.
I'm going to chart the route.
I'm going to tell you beforehand
what to grab out of that bowl
if you show up at the door
and there's just a bowl there.
We're going to
strategize together.
Am I going to look like me
with maybe, you know, a funky
little cat ears on my head?
That's what we have to do.
What's more important?
-They will learn to value that
as they get older.
And I think once they hit
their mid to late teens,
they're going to really hate
Taran for taking it
so seriously.
-You're right.
Really being imaginative
and creative.
I think so. I think so.
That's my hope.
-Um, Taran is also
in "Impeachment."
And I would imagine
one of the most fun things
about doing a show like this
is getting to sit back
and watch the other wonderful
performances by this great cast.
-Yeah, for sure.
He actually got hired
on the project first.
And because of him,
I was able --
He felt the tone of the set,
and he was having
such a great time.
The crew was amazing
on this one,
and he was having such a blast
that it made me not,
you know, totally terrified
to play Ann Coulter.
Um, he -- It was a little bit
more exciting after that.
We didn't have
any scenes together,
but I think that our scenes
sometimes line up
where his scene ends
and then I'm in the next one,
which is interesting
and new for us.
-What was it like
growing up in Canada
while this was all going down?
Was the impeachment scandal
and drama something
that you were all watching
the same way we were here?
-I mean, we certainly got
the news up north, for sure,
but I was, you know,
16, 17 and very self-involved.
And so I was just
kind of focused on,
you know, my own stuff.
But I do remember broad strokes.
I do remember -- A lot of it
is actually "SNL" sketches.
I mean, a lot of those
kind of jokey references
I definitely --
-A deeply unfortunate way
to learn history.
It should be noted.
-Absolutely. Somewhat
inaccurate. Somewhat inaccurate.
Um, but, so I did know
sort of the moments,
but it has been an education.
And I'm in -- You know, I'm not
in every one of these episodes,
so I'm kind of learning
as I go a lot
and also did a lot of research
beforehand.
So it was like --
I learned a lot about
this time in history, so...
-Do you get to keep the wig
at least?
It's a very iconic wig.
-Oh, I mean, it would have been
at least something
for Halloween, yeah.
Um, no, no, I didn't.
That wig -- There was so much
work done for that look.
It was, like,
a prized possession
of that hair department.
So, no, I didn't get to keep it.
-I got to be honest.
If I was a neighborhood kid
and I knew you to be an integral
part of the Marvel Universe,
I'd be pretty bummed out if you
walked out as weird cat lady.
-Okay.
We got to get some spandex.
We got to figure it out.
-Just something.
Just some effort.
-It's coming.
-It's always wonderful
to see you.
Loved your family,
and I look forward to next time.
-Definitely, Seth. Take care.
-"Impeachment:
American Crime Story"
airs Tuesdays only on FX.